hey leute und willkommen zur snapshot
video vom neuen erschienenen snapshot 12
w 39a ich trage hier noch den skin von
agent 197 und zwar einfach weil er beim
letzten video wo ich dieses genauer an
hatte
das war der die redstone klopp da wird
der ski nicht angezeigt ihr habt ihn
noch mal als ich von den ganz
interessant mit dem blauen und so rüsten
bisschen einfallsreicher also deswegen
habe ich dir noch mal eine weile jetzt
einfach funktioniert und ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt an und zwar geben wir
den chat times 20.000 ein weil das
meiste sind änderungen über nacht
erschienen sind und zwar leuchtet der
ofen ich habe jetzt einfach mal so ein
paar sachen eingepackt der erleuchtet
nur noch nach vorne das heißt nach
hinten nicht ich kann das mal ganz kurz
hier zu bauen damit ihr das hier seht
also der leuchte echt nicht mehr nach
hinten das sind jetzt natürlich immer
noch ein paar extra beleuchtung die
jedoch von der von dem kürbis kommen von
anderen seite aber der leuchtet halt
nicht mehr nach hinten das heißt der
macht euer haus nicht mehr komplett hell
sondern der leuchtet nur noch zu dieser
seite hin
das wurde geändert dann wurden die
lichtverhältnisse von diesem kaktus hier
geändert von diesem pumpkin dinge 2 lädt
schon erleuchtet wenn ich weiter hof
liege der leuchtet bis da ungefähr hin
dass es immens weit das ist fast schon
weiter ist als eine fackel glaube ich
ich kenne mich da nicht ganz so aus
allerdings wird das auch von chep
gepostet m und außerdem gibt es bei
lichtern nun nicht mehr die bucks dass
zwischen diesen treppen da licht
hindurch kommt und auch nicht bei diesen
half stones tabs also das sind alle
möglichen treppen und hamster und steps
dies gibt das labs glaube ich dies gibt
dann hörte ja immer schon dass dieses
sonst ein wenig anders sind ich mache
immer wieder ganz kurz ein bisschen
lauter damit ihr das hört
so darf jetzt gratis ans gehört ich habe
ja beim letzten mal schon gezeigt
allerdings hat dinner bauen und jazz
zusammen haben bei twitter gepostet dass
die sounds nochmal ein wenig verändert
wurden habe ich bisher noch nicht so
viel von gemerkt aber das liegt
wahrscheinlich auch daran dass ich immer
noch in der 1.3 punkt zwei spieler noch
nicht im snapshot und diese sounds
allgemeiner nicht so viel zu hören
bekommen habe also die haupt änderung
sind einfach dass ein paar licht bugs
behoben wurden und lichttechnisch ein
bisschen was verändert wurde
du kannst gleich erstmal baden gehen und
zusammen cool ich will einfach sagen
wenn ich das video gefallen hat würde
ich mich über einen daumen hoch freuen
wenn ich so gut findet natürlich über
einen daumen runter mit konstruktiver
kritik schreibt mir doch mal die
kommentare was ihrem coolsten findet an
diesem tollen neuen neuerungen oder ob
ich allgemein die entwicklung in die
minecraft gefällt und dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns beim nächsten video
zschau